it was finally time for nasa to launch
artemis 1 the first step in going back
to the moon but then nasa called a scrub
for today partly because of a problem
while fueling the rocket with liquid
hydrogen there was a leak
at that vent valve
so a few days later they tried again and
nasa called a scrub
for the launch attempt today again
because of problems with liquid hydrogen
it was a much larger leak
hydrogen is difficult to work with it's
why spacex and blue origin are designing
rockets that won't use it our next
generation rockets will be
using methane as a fuel
here's why nasa is using liquid hydrogen
even while spacex is moving away from it
and why it's causing delays to the
artemis launch
liquid hydrogen packs the most power of
any fuel when it comes to the energy it
holds nearly three times that of
gasoline when it's mixed with liquid
oxygen
hydrogen although it's difficult to work
with it is the best propellant for
giving you the maximum
change in momentum of your rocket for a
finite amount of rocket fuel dr philip
metzger spent nearly 30 years at nasa
and worked on the space shuttle launch
team we had trouble in the space shuttle
program with hydrogen leaks like in 1990
a columbia mission was scrubbed three
times because of hydrogen leaks even the
very last mission of space shuttle
discovery was once officially scrubbed
because of a hydrogen gas leak
the molecules are so tiny they're made
of two hydrogen atoms and the hydrogen
atom is literally the smallest atom in
the whole cosmos
most of the trouble lies in keeping it
in liquid form which happens when it's
very very cold negative
423 degrees
the challenge lies in fueling the
hydrogen tank which is inside this
orange part called the core stage this
tank has to be incredibly well insulated
and specially sealed to deal with those
tiny molecules and the extreme cold but
using liquid hydrogen also causes
problems with other connected parts
because the temperature is so low
every time you try to flow the hydrogen
from the tank into the engine through
pipes and valves
all the materials are going to shrink
because of the cold temperature which
causes little tiny cracks to open up so
then those tiny atoms tiny molecules can
get through the cracks these
complexities are one reason why spacex's
starship is being designed to instead
use liquid methane
methane doesn't leak as much for a
couple of reasons for one thing it is a
much larger molecule in the end
engineering is applied physics and so it
always comes back to some basic physics
principles like the size of the atom
that causes these problems liquid
methane isn't as powerful as liquid
hydrogen but it is easier to work with
it doesn't have to be kept as cold so
the tanks don't need the same extreme
insulation there are also fewer problems
with the connecting valves and pipes
it's a much more benign propellant to
deal with as an engineering problem
spacex also has a good reason to use
liquid methane scientists think it can
be made on mars
so the rocket that will eventually go to
the red planet their goal is the same
that could bring people back to earth
so why is nasa still using tiny leaky
liquid hydrogen
one reason it's part of a system that
they've used for decades
another is because of this 2010
congressional bill that first funded the
rocket system now used for artemis it
says nasa should use the existing
workforce and assets which includes
existing contracts and propulsion
systems hydrogen the politicians and the
policy planners
were trying to come up with a program
that we could fit in the national budget
and they decided let's reuse space
shuttle hardware it's a decision that
people argue about still
the head of nasa former senator bill
nelson who helped pass the bill defended
the decision to continue using liquid
hydrogen after the second artemis scrub
we did not have
any question about hydrogen we deferred
to the experts even though nasa has
repaired hydrogen leaks before artemis
is using nearly all new parts so the
scrubs aren't surprising to people like
dr metzger this is a growing pain
even if you're using the same components
from the space shuttle just the act of
putting it together in a new vehicle is
going to guarantee that you'll have
challenges to work through i mean it
could be something as simple as the way
you routed the pipe
causing a little bit of side loading on
the pipe causing it to torque the
connector which causes a leak you know
it could be any small little thing
although we are having more leaks than a
system that's based in methane or
another repellent it's not going to be
like this forever
nasa said these leaks are just part of
the process of a new system and are
confident that they will be fixed for
future artemis launches but as long as
they're using liquid hydrogen leaks and
scrubs are always possible